you ready oh I'm ready no money i watch
this so many times but I never thought
about you never thought about how that
happened no I just like I was watching
you know every time you Fran start
knowing semi black eye here comes some
[ __ ] let me see what just let me see
what nonsense got going on and dude I
saw the first uh I think I saw the one
that you did with Dane Cook yeah yeah
but that was over at all things comedy
studio I didn't want to I got tired of
driving to Burbank and then I having
these weird times all right I was having
people having to come to Burbank at like
6:00 in the afternoon
oh that's the worst yeah yeah it just
was a nightmare so I changed so I said
you know what let me do this here and
it's been evolving to some right you
know I mean y'all see what I see
[Laughter]
my good friend the very funny talented
writer actor comedian mr. David Arnold
hey guys thanks for watching with from
with Griffin make sure you go to my
website Erik Griffin comm if you want to
see my tour dates I'm coming to the
Dayton funny bone as of this podcast and
that's right after that I'm going to
Detroit for the Motor City Comedy
Festival then we
and after that I'll be at the Ontario
improv so make sure you check that out
for all you guys out there that want to
come see me live
but today's podcast is brought to you by
my bookie so I want to thank my bookie
for supporting with him with Griffin
my bookie has better bonuses and more
prop bets than any other sports bug
period
this year's are hosting the first online
handicapping super contest first place
is guaranteed to win at least $100,000
and it only costs $100 to enter visit my
bookie online today and use the promo
code Griffin when creating your account
to claim the bonuses now let's get back
to the podcast what's that man and you
know what it's funny cuz you you say
like I always could I had you on my
phone as Dave yes a lot of people call
you Dave Arnold so then when did you
like only you know that's not true when
did you become so boozy that you like
David Arnold and I need a let me tell
you what happens I think there is a
sound composer who does all of the movie
there sounded soundtracks for James Bond
and other big movies his name is David
Arnold ah and so like when I started
like really getting credits and making
money it became an issue so look so like
last year ya know so I it became an
issue and I was like and here's the
thing
when I first came out here I always had
David Arnold because I was a huge fan of
Michael J Fox so I thought it was cool
to have your middle initial let it go
when I first got here I let it go then I
realized oh I need it especially because
like the internet searching your name
and stuff like that and when you have
somebody who's you know more famous than
you
that's the sucky part that's the part
that you know you'd be like if your name
was like you know Jamie P Fox you need
that because if not but then he hit me
on I think on Twitter David Arnold oh we
do
yes and he said I didn't know I was a
funny black guy
so you know that's crazy I have a Eric
Griffin I have there's a guy named Eric
Griffin blue with a CE o and that's the
problem with it is that's if you hear
Eric Griffin trying to go search for
your first thing it's gonna be or I see
gee that's my yes yes that's true and
he's just like punk rock tourist okay
say so you know and he's got Eric
Griffin that calm but he doesn't do
anything with it I'm just trying to get
it cuz I just wanted to get both I just
want I have just if people go to it they
can still find me but ya see something
now you just have to become more popular
you know but I it still comes I still
come up right under me I think I'm
famous enough now whatever that
searchable mas searchable you because
more people cuz you see people will put
like like so for me they'll put like
Eric Griffin workaholics or Eric Griffin
yes whatever you put in if people put in
David Arnold comedian yeah they don't
need that but most of the time like now
when I do shows and you know when I'm
coming to a club I make sure that it's
David a Arnall do you come up as like
when you're doing shows and like do tell
the MC please say David a Arnold oh I
you know what I I don't think I'd do
that I think that they naturally do it
now because it's it and it's got to the
point now where everybody well I have to
like reintroduce you ladies and
gentlemen welcome to the podcast David a
what the music I'm really excited to be
here because like you know everybody has
a podcast yeah I don't like you know
like all of them I don't like all of
those just like you don't like
everybody's Instagram or - exactly
that's the way it is right now right
exactly I mean but your is to people
that bug the [ __ ] out of me about being
on the podcast okay okay I'm one of them
you're one of them and the other one is
ariari Spears
he loves beer you gonna fight him if he
come in yeah well he went to he went I
had him on all things comedy oh then you
have to watch that episode
okay I'm gonna watch it trip is it
is that the one where he went off on
somebody no no nose I know he was on one
part out everybody
he was cool well he actually had a good
talk we got into like cuz I told him I
said cuz it was funny he said to me uh
he was like he was like you know he's
very persistent yes he was like hitting
me up like you know I don't wanna be
that dude but like you know right set up
a date you know right no he doesn't call
arrogant customer you don't tell people
he was like you know using I know what
comes off as an [ __ ] and I was like
oh if for sure does it want to talk
about it on the pocket I wanted to come
on because I liked it because everybody
that you have on here are all my friends
hmm
and I it's you know what it is it felt
like comedians talking about comedy yeah
yeah that's which that's the only thing
that I'm interested in no I hear you
it's really like comedians in cars
getting coffee to me like comedians in
an apartment but I didn't have coffee
and so like when I was watching the most
like oh they're having real
conversations yeah sometimes it just
goes where it goes yes like that like
Gary Owen came on yes for some reason we
started talking about like our worst
stories right and it just turned into
like what it turned into
so you know it's dope yeah and I hope
ours turns into something like you know
cut to us like nothing but I know you uh
cuz you have a radio show right I did I
stopped doing it I had to stop doing it
when I started producing fuller house on
Netflix because of my schedule producer
writer yes we're in our last season
we're doing 18 episodes so I'm there
through November so our production
schedule got in the way of the radio
show but I'm actually in the process of
developing another one for actual radio
instead of a podcast I'm actually doing
it with some a woman who created a Steve
Harvey and do Hughley show and Rickey
smiley show oh yeah those hurdles good
stuff
yeah so we're still admit to me it's
still extension yes if it's being put
out as a podcast later it's still a
podcast I guess it could be yeah
is that alike yeah yeah I'm doing
actually a test with a co-host a
potential co-host today at 5 o'clock oh
that's great yeah is it female yes it is
yes that's what the that's the world we
live in
well that's what I want yeah I'm more
comfortable having round women having a
because you have like you you have two
daughters to have a two daughters I'm a
wife of my two daughters and I have I
grew up I'm the only boy I got all
sisters
oh [ __ ] where'd you grow up Cleveland
you kinda know you was from Cleveland
and raised born and raised in Cleveland
and raised in Cleveland and I all my
life I've been around all women I mean
my dad was in the house but I'm saying
you know my stepfather you know my dad's
definitely a stepfather to yes but it
was like but see my stepfather was later
in life now mine was like there oh so he
was he had he was he was he was you know
he was but my dad was also in my life as
well so I didn't like really yes my
father was very active in my life he
bevery every weekend I went there when
it was parent-teacher conference I was
the only kid that has six parents show
up I wasn't I was 12 and like my aunt
who lived out here at the time she was
on with her husband and my grandmother
and grandfather so my whole family was
on family few right my grandfather who
at home in Cleveland's watched Family
Feud religiously every day answered
every question Wow Wow
my grandmother would just sit there
watch with nothing we got on TV they got
on TV he just famous say [ __ ] it's under
the bright lights man those bright
lights be like people freeze he got to
add on his name all my friends like a
David and because we just got killed our
family got destroyed we didn't my mother
answered every question really she was
the only one to answer every question
everybody else died in what a man family
feel like do you ever see yourself like
wanted to do something like that like be
the host of family feud no yeah yes I
mean like we look at people who host you
know to me like all the comedian's
who hold a you know who's the guys at
hope we got Louie Anderson Louie
Anderson you have it Steve Harvey that's
the only two that I can read well but
but even all the other TV show all the
other game shows period oh okay like
let's make a deal you know I feel like
comedians we go there because you know
we you even get a check but I don't
think any comedian ever takes to
microphone and goes one day I'm gonna
host family feud I don't think that
stick I don't knows just part of me that
feels like I would love to host family
feud just cuz I would just remember
until I was a kid Richard yeah like
richard dawson I just remember him like
he blow he could meet a host anymore
because he would've got canceled
cuz yeah you can't be kissing me he was
all about like come here girl yeah no no
I
as for me as I can Steve Harvey so nasty
I never watched Steve Harvey do it oh
unit you gotta watch to you parse all
clips it's funny first of all it's
always like the Jackson family his whole
thing is like like I'm asking you a
question you answered me he'll go like
this right that's where all Steve's
comedy come on I don't never yeah for me
as a comic I've always wanted to be I
think a comedian I just wanted to prove
what kind of comedian the kind that
people want to come see like I wanna I
wanna I wanna of the subsections of
comedy if you even think there's
subsections of comedy how would you
like well what sort of comedian would
you consider yourself uh I don't know
what that means like I I'm just asking
because sometimes it's like you know you
think what because it's like are you
observational comic you figure your
storyteller I'm a storyteller but I'm
observe a tional in the area you know I
love and I always have
I've always loved the dynamics of family
relationships yeah that's always been my
thing even I've always wanted I wanted
to play a father on television when I
was single with no kids like I couldn't
wait to get old enough to be able to
play a dad right that was that was from
the day I came to this town the only
thing I've ever wanted to do was to be
able to fit in that do this to sitcom
jobs show jobs I thought my dream job is
to be a lab tech on CSI Wow I was a lab
tech in real life like I'm like a really
when I was in there when I was in you in
the Navy this is great uh you must be
good friends but did you know uh Gary
Owen you guys never talk I started Gary
Owens doing staying okay cool I helped
him I said yeah go that way and I went
to the Navy and came back on top of the
world I wanted to be a lab tech on CSI
yesterday because as a comic I thought
listen it'll be like this the lead
people come in you know and I'm like
well I got the blood work and I'm one of
those dudes with the music's playing
I'm so sorry boss you know yeah yeah
what a DNA shows this I'm there I do
like right two days of work a week yeah
I'm on the road as did that dude you
know I said that's a perfect and what's
the other job I want to be fat sitcom
dad
that's hilarious yeah I just wanted to
you know so and I haven't achieved that
but but isn't but that's the great thing
about what we do it's not it's over
it's not over it's never over but you
you've been all right we'll see you
actually you worked for Tyler Perry so
there I will have it
I've yeah what were you gonna say
you got to say something you went but
[ __ ] is like kids like like there's
there's you know I've worked on a couple
of you know three camera sitcoms yeah
and as much as I thought I wanted to do
that yeah it was terrible I hated every
moment of it as an actor as an actor
why oh okay okay as a guest star got it
is terrible
right I did one day at a time okay and
so I have one scene rise like the first
scene in the pilot oh oh okay it's a far
scene in a pilot everybody's nervous
she's a nurse and I was a patient daddy
and I had interaction right now the
first thing about it was like the
director I wish I could remember her
name but she's that female director
that's been directing for 40 Linda
Mendoza
no not Mindy she's a white lady but
she's like been in it forever okay but
she's the most meticulous like if this
was a scene yeah she would be like this
I think I want this yeah yeah yeah yeah
they can do that do it again yeah and
she wanted running out and she wanted
the words she said hold on to the script
because I want you to get the words
right right so it was like that kind of
like okay cool but the schedule was like
9:00 to like whatever it was and I had
one scene right so I had to wait in my
so I would do my scene first we have a
read-through yes do the scene all the
little meticulous [ __ ] with that the
notes change and then the notes okay
then it was I had to wait because it was
a nope session yes it was a Netflix
notes yes it was a CEO and a studio and
network I know it's a Norman Lear notes
oh wow yeah okay it's right so I was
like damn if you're not the star of
something or in every scene this is a
lot of sit around it isn't well yeah
that's what I mean that's what we do
even at fuller house we have to run
throughs we have a run-through for
studio and for the network you know and
then the actors have their notes and
ideas the student Netflix and Warner
Brothers well let me ask you this the
difference between single cam and three
camera in my opinion they're what makes
one good or bad
yeah in the three camera I realize that
is all the director M and writers or the
reason why it's bad
because of a multicam of a multicam
because is so meticulous about where
we're gonna stand what we're gonna do
and what we're gonna say they have
controlled this to the point where this
is what they want presented right now
with a single cam you take you're doing
five six seven take right your
performance so then it's you in the
editor yes makes it but I just noticed
what do you think the difference is for
you cuz you've worked how you've worked
on both right here's the thing this is
someone what you're saying is true but
when you you also got to remember like
the experience you're talking about
right now is from a pilot yeah
everybody's nervous if the stakes are
very high
yeah everybody wants everything to be
right everybody so what I found is that
when you're working on something where
the stakes are high whatever it is and
you have a lot of input that can kill
the creative side of things all right
now for me as a comedian who stands in
and and standing there as a producer and
a writer I can see those two worlds
collide everybody sees this thing from
through their lens yeah the actor seizes
through the ed to the eye of the actor
and creatively and I have to and the
writer is there about the word he said
she instead of you know she said it's
instead of it is like they literally get
hump I've never gotten hung up on that
as a writer and a producer like I feel
like we can over produce and overwrite
and over and you [ __ ] up the the real
funny yeah yeah so you were in a
situation where you were a guest star
they don't give a [ __ ] about you they
sure day-day want you to not [ __ ] up
they pilot but you know the thing is
what I noticed too was like I was like
they're not even a word that we're gonna
get laughs at a point that they don't
even cuz isn't right so when the
audience came in right we're doing this
scene I'm do I did they laughed at a
point where it was like we did there was
nothing in the rehearsal she said it was
gonna be allowed to deal with the laughs
at that moment right and then like for a
comic like you know you know you know
that audience is there you know you
shine
I'm like you know I'm ready to just was
like it was like a weird thing it's
funny you talked about I guess producer
writer like right I remember visiting
the set of Whitney you know yes I was
lady coming we wouldn't be Whitney
comment witness said cuz I'm good I did
one of her first shows I wrote produced
one on her first show she was the
co-host for Tony rock on the Tony rock
project
I hope [ __ ] I didn't know that I was the
producer writer on that why was good I'm
good Chris D'Elia is one of my best
friends so I'm just on set you know and
I'm watching and on a network sitcom yes
the writers area that is the most
pressure cooker thing I've ever seen
okay yeah because it's like you see that
like someone else start pacing and yes
what it is is they're jokes about the
[Laughter]
other writers are like ecosystem of like
a the writers of the writers and
producers and everything and then and
then I don't feel that you know it
exists
but I don't feel that why not why not
because I'm a working stand-up comedian
yes yeah I think that's what a working
stand-up comedian I know what's funny I
get I'm going to get laughs outside of
this script some writers and producers
if they don't get that moment right
that's it for them for to be you know
I'm saying like to be there for me and
you I'll be there watching every I've
been in situations where it's very oh I
got a joke in yeah I don't I'll give you
a joke if you like it cool if you don't
I don't see and cuz I'm going to the
comedy club tonight or that weekend I'm
gonna be standing in front of 500 people
and I'm gonna get a standing ovation you
know I'm gonna get that little thing
that writers and producers don't get
like we do as comedians oh that's
interesting yeah that's that's an
interesting thought process yeah you
know it doesn't hit me like I've never
and it can come off in that world as if
you don't care yeah two writers and
producers he don't care well you know
what he knows this is funny is like I
I've recognized this sort of delicate
ecosystem is the best way to describe it
so like I tell comics actors new people
like you know when you go into something
cuz sometimes it's like you ever you
were going first where you go to the
audition and right like you know they
say make it your own
yeah yes are you my boom boom boom so
then maybe at the table read whatever it
is like that I'm always leery of like I
want to make sure that that's okay
because you know your cupcake is you're
a writer and you've went you've done all
this work that's a good way to look at
it to get this script here and then here
I come as an actor and I'm like you know
I don't think I could do this better
it's one of those things where you never
know if that choice is gonna be right or
not cuz you could be working with a
group of people who think it's great
that you added something that was yes or
you could be working with a group of
people that are offended that you added
something that's funnier than what they
came up with yes of we're you know this
is so weird you know no delicate
delicate ecosystem because cuz I
remember being on okay I remember Tom
Papa had this pilot ya know yeah and I
remember I was on the road yeah
Hollywood okay so that's my wife number
one so okay so this would be this what I
can't stand they'll you know they'll get
a project together it's a it's a network
show they're gonna yes they go they take
three months they got that actor that
they like and boom yeah they go through
the testing process right and then
that's when they go we don't like this
[ __ ] yeah and then they go but
we need somebody in three days yes
they've taken three months with this
person who's gone through so that's what
happened yes so like I'm on the road in
like yo Eric put it the audition tape
together now the thing that I can't
stand about first of all I love
auditioning I love doing tapes right oh
wow cuz you're the first person I've
ever seen that the reason is is because
I could do as may take
oh god if you doing self tape self tape
people who don't know what self tape as
an actor like you know you like here you
at the house you turn your camera on you
do the audition with a friend of yours
who's off camera and you present and you
send the tape in yourself so it's not
like you went to the studio and read
with our casting yeah you put it
together yourself and you send it to us
and we look there's two reasons well I
like that better
first of all you reading with a casting
director sometimes they just they don't
care don't care they go they can you
[ __ ] they don't give you them your not
giving you nothing so you will be here
like what am i you know all right so
then so all right so here's a problem no
I'm on a road by myself I don't know the
features I'm just so like I I had to set
this whole thing up where I recorded
myself on my phone right used my laptop
right and I was doing the audition with
myself oh but I did it so many times and
I really liked what I was doing right
sure enough I got to call back I got I
go in the first thing they said was
how'd you do that which by the way I
feel like I need to invent an app there
should be ads for self auditioning you
say the thing and then you know you know
that's kind of dope I know I'm who's I'm
really trying to think about it any app
developers out there hit me up but
anyways I go in yeah I read with Tom you
know and the producers right I'm gonna
go in again right I'm gonna yeah
the studio never you networked all this
[ __ ] right that's not even the tests
yeah I'm doing the way I'm doing it you
know then I get to test mm-hmm I use my
tape for the studio test right but they
want me to come in for the networked yes
I denied before the network test I get
this call from Tom papa you know Eric
CBS yes they like they want you to be
grounded you know they don't want it too
big they don't want to anything okay
so already I'm like so the thing I've
been doing to get me here to get me to
this point you're saying don't do that
okay
they is their thing he's the star right
I go in do the thing the test as I leave
the room I leave the room the two
producers come running out Eric Eric
Eric
you can do it again remember that note
we
you forget that note and go back in and
do do you what you've been doing sure
enough I didn't get that part and they
gave it to malcolm-jamal Warner who they
were doing his deal the whole time you
were running back and forth this thing
has never been fine let me just say it
like that because celebrity is going to
trump but what they did funny but
everyday what they did was they took
away yeah they they took away your thing
not only that no no but they also like
they they downgraded apart from series
regular to like oh he's just gonna be
recurring yes and then we'll give it to
this dude that we think is a you know
and I'm just bitter Warner is great you
know let me put that out there you you
dope I just mad you know what I'm saying
yeah but but here's the good news bad
news the pilot didn't go it didn't even
go and Mastiffs are they not only didn't
want you they didn't want a show nothing
about this was good and by the way you
know and I know this is what happened
and I've talked about this on the
podcast already but this is a great
example of it and you've probably but
see you were you gonna do this but we'll
get into you after after me I'm just
thinking about like I know that the part
wasn't supposed to be as someone of
color at all normally it's never it
never is
no but this particularly you let me tell
you I you know when it's when it's
supposed to be somebody of color because
the way it's written which is 95% of the
time it's written by a white boy or
somebody white doing what they think
people of ethnic backgrounds would sound
like yeah if it that's the only way you
know it should be
they really had somebody of color in
mind when it's bad ethnic writing yeah
yeah yeah but if it's just regular like
there's a Kwanzaa reference yeah no
reason to get it pop it some old
reference tree to me and you know it's
like this is them trying to do an ethnic
voice yeah and you know but most of the
time it's for white person
I knew I know Tom said like I think it
was like one of these things where was
like he was like we had to show you know
and it's like and then they're like they
looking at like oh god we made an
all-white show let's uh we'd ever know
this let's put it out there for like
some like you know let's get some people
to come in and I'm a great catch all
right get Griffin you know let's just
seaweed let's see if we want them to be
Mexican yeah you know so they like it
they have like a weird you know so I
don't know it's just like a weird I'm
just saying that it's just a weird
process and go through all that it is
you know excited I have another horror
story about this Matt LeBlanc show but
but you were but now cuz you've worked
on I don't want to say black sitcoms and
white sitcoms but I'm saying but yeah
but you have I wrote row house of pain
and meet the Browns for Tyler Perry
which was an experience that I walked
away from realizing that both of them
are right and wrong meaning him in
Hollywood
oh yeah Perry Tyler Tyler Perry's way of
doing it is has some rights and wrongs
in Hollywood's way of doing it yeah has
arrived I mean I I watched everybody you
know they don't the bottom line is they
don't respect people who have worked on
those shows that's period let's just put
it out there do use any Hollywood
Hollywood laugh if you do Tyler Perry
show they're not gonna be like without
let's throw that [ __ ] all CBS
know they don't like I like you know I I
hope I helped run house of pain and meet
the Browns nobody here respects me as a
showrunner or the fact that I they don't
even acknowledge it yet we did the same
thing we they're casting we did all of
the same stuff and as the same thing is
the type of comedy and trying to do it
you know they went through a pier where
they tried to do the 1090 that's how I
yeah that's how I've ended up on
partners for Kelsey Grammer and Martin
Lawrence I wrote that [ __ ] right which
was bad you not I mean and I felt like
it was it was bad for a few reasons you
know I mean what are one of those
reasons well one that show probably
should have been on TV land and not on
FX but it was before TV land knew who
they were when they were trying to do
the old sitcom entrances that's where
they should have been over there and I
feel like don't you just took two guys
and
yeah you just took two guys and throw
them together mm-hmm
because it's martin lawrence and kelsey
Grammer's just to see oh this should be
you know because we you know they
figured that would sell it but it just
it didn't like frazier and right and
martin and it was just it was it was not
good but what i learned is like all the
things that they criticize tyler perry
about doing 10 and 90 and doing ollie
they now was trying to do it you know
they're saying sounds like you watch
everybody it always starts off you know
like as as as actors writers comedians
doing podcast whatever we do you have to
go through a period of criticism yeah of
people telling you all that ain't gonna
be that you ain't [ __ ] what kind of week
and then when you push through that
criticism then you come on the other
side of that and all of a sudden you're
this brilliant guy who thought of right
right doing this particularly see
although that it was a marble block at
first it was them we had to chisel away
at did nobody ever sees that part nobody
ever sees anytime you try to do
something new and something different
you're going to be criticized for it and
then when it becomes successful not only
are you gonna be praised but then other
people are going to try to do exactly
what you're doing
you know them saying so like as a
comedian for me like that's that's the
biggest like i all of this stems from me
doing stand-up it's being able to write
being able to produce the acting all of
it it comes from the basis of i want
people to want to see me perform right
like if I could if somebody came to me
and said you can never write another
script again I'd be fine oh really
yeah I don't need to do that I do that
because I can not because I want to
write just a skill you have it's a skill
that I have they pay me a lot of money
to do it so why not go do it yeah and it
makes me better in being in that space
yeah I get you you know what I'm saying
but as a but I'm a comedian I'm like you
know like that's the thing that's the
thing I gotta do you have no regrets
though like say dude you're Tyler Perry
years because like what were the real
Brett what was the pros and cons the
pros where I've made money okay go
obviously you know the other Pro was
that I learned I did get a skill I
sharpened the skill and got an
opportunity to do something that I
wouldn't have gotten to do here and the
way that I got to do it I wrote a
hundred and twenty episodes I worked on
a hundred and twenty episodes of TV in
three years
Scott sure you know it takes ten years
to do that in this town yeah so I was
able to do that and then the other cons
were I was outside of the system for
three years cuz I was in Atlanta going
back and forth and you know to this day
right now somebody come on go you're
still in Atlanta they've been in Atlanta
in ten years but people will still go
you still like you know good so you know
you step outside and you're outside the
system you're not building up your
points and things in the system you know
so like I think that was the biggest con
but for me that one of the biggest pros
is it made me realize I'm a comedian
even making money writing and even
making money producing and doing it I
thought my I was nervous at first then
when I first started making money that
it would diminish my well yeah but it
would also make me not have the desire
to get on stage at night and go to a
comedy club it gives some art I know
when I've worked on shows I've been you
know as an actor you know it's like the
6:00 a.m. call be tired but it don't
take away your thing of being a comedian
the moment that's over moment you wrap
yeah you go to the comedy class don't
try to book shows yes then I just found
myself being like boo but that lends
itself to like making sure you more
healthy and take care of yourself that's
why you're comedian to actor and all the
other things you do comes from that I'm
a comedian everything else stems from me
being a comic I love like I can't not do
it yeah I feel you you know the
Instagram stuff that I started doing was
an extension of me doing it because I
wanted to find a way to get my voice to
people so they would want to come see me
perform I know it's like we these
old-school do's to try to find a
new-school way to like you know you know
and you you're doing you know you have
your what you involve your family I just
captured my life somebody asked me
yesterday like
did I think about you know oh I want to
put my wife on camera and my kids it was
I what I do on Instagram and Facebook
and all that has never been with an
agenda it was never like oh if I put my
wife and kids it's gonna make me pee no
I only know to show you who I am
authentically I'm a father I got a wife
I got two daughters that's my life if I
get on stage you're gonna know who I am
that's what I do I don't know what else
to talk about I might look at some of
your videos I'm like your wife she just
loved doing that stuff I bet she
prepares that my makeup I can just 100
we we did a sketch where we getting out
of bed it's a little bit of both if I
never came to her again and turn the
camera on
she would never ask how can we not doing
a video okay because my wife is my wife
was a very accomplished Broadway dancer
oh really yes my wife was the third
african-american to dance on line with
the Radio City Rockettes oh wow she was
their spokesperson she danced with Jimmy
Buffett for many years he was in his bag
yeah she did Guys and Dolls with Carol
Channing like she my wife was very
commercial actress oh wow Julie doesn't
need any more mm-hmm accolades or stroke
of her Eagle to notice she is or was
successful in front of a camera so she's
very good that means she was very
supportive as a partner yeah are you
gonna go on a town you gotta go when I
met her she was tour with Jimmy Buffett
Oh see so she was all out she was out of
town right we both were like when we
dated she was you know we would end up
in some of the same cities where I would
fly from where I am to meet her and I'll
Modesto that's when it was fun that's
what y'all ruined it with Marion
now we both for the house looking at the
TV no [ __ ] you go dance someplace
that's what I love about Julie because
she's so she gets it she's very talented
and so if we're gonna do it she's very
good at doing it right but she doesn't
I was I was dating her for several
months before I knew what she did for a
living
oh that's good she's not one of those
women go you know I did Julie I'll hang
with you for two years and you'll never
know I think that's the best kind of
people that's why well she's from
Indianapolis I'm from Cleveland it's
that Midwest you know I had a but at a
buddy of mine his is still my buddy but
he just travels so much I knew him for
three years and he was a younger dude
you know and he just we just hit it off
you know you came to one of my shows I
became a fan but then we just hit it off
cuz he's such an interesting cat right
it was three years before I said to him
dude what what do you do right I never
see you at work right you always
traveling right he was like I am with my
great great grandfather was Walt Disney
Wow
like you open with [ __ ] like that true
and I had so much more respect for Matt
he's hidden that he never liked it never
was something that even knew because
then I started to think like why aren't
we going to Disneyland all the time what
free passes why you keep bringing me
here I get it it's the happiest place on
earth can we just go have a beer why are
you acting like this
yeah I I think I think it all stems from
who you are and I feel like we get
caught up in this business of what we do
is the only identity that we have I've
had I enjoy I know what you're saying so
I enjoyed there's this dude that comes
to the comedy store okay and he is this
older do but like a hipster in his right
you know look like he's you know so he
comes up to me one day and he says hey
man I really am a huge fan
like very humble and write huge fan I
would really I would love it if you came
dude performed at my 50th birthday party
Wow
but you know you don't really it's like
birthday you like okay I was being
trying to be real with him like she did
you fam but I just don't see myself
standing in whatever else it will send
me an email because it yeah I got just
sort of a
show email right uh you know I mean like
I'm you know right and I was like okay
and I said all right labels go give me I
was like you know give me that to come
to your place right okay so I can start
going to a place I'm driving in the
Hills man right I'm getting closer and
closer to the Hollywood song right
that's where this [ __ ] lives
right I walk in all these people are in
and he's dressed in a beautiful ass suit
okay with his hair like Mikey never seen
yes yes and I was like who is this
[ __ ] platinum gold records on
the wall Wow you thought he was coming
to see you all these years is actually
me no Betancourt he's part of extreme
you know more heroic more than words
you know Wow Rihanna's musical director
Wow see the wall I go hey man open with
this I'm Rihanna's music director open
with it hi I don't know if you know and
I would have been like because in that
moment but here's the thing to what I
like about me right as I went right
without knowing that exactly because of
how he approached me right I went right
I didn't need that yes but it would have
helped I wouldn't have such a bad
attitude driving up there you have to
heal what's up y'all sorry for the
interruption but I just want to talk to
you once again about my bookie football
season is here and I'm super excited
as of today actually Antonio Brown was
cut from the radio's before he even
played what a nightmare that is Odell
Beckham over at Cleveland I can't wait
to see what that's gonna look like levy
on bail with the Jets can't wait to see
what that's gonna look like the Colts
without Andrew Luck if you want to bet
on the games and you want to bet
responsibly and I know you're
responsible because you're watching with
him with Griffin so my bookie is the
place to bet on football every single
week my bookie has better bonuses and
more profits than any other sports book
period all you got to do is pick five
NFL games against the spread every week
to climb the leaderboard and score your
share of the huge cash prize pool that's
the kind of stuff that goes on at my
bookie
I love it because you could bet on how
many fantasy points your fantasy team is
gonna get I've been planning the same
fantasy league for like 20 years and so
now I could bet on the real football
games and I could bet on my fantasy team
that's pretty dope I recommend my bookie
to all my listeners cuz my bookies been
good to me that's why my bookie is
always the right play you bet you win
they pay my bookie has live in game
betting on every NFL game in game
betting all they've got the most
rewarding player perks in the business
and for your fantasy guys out there you
can even bet the over under and how many
fantasy points a player will score each
game that is absolutely my favorite part
about it up to $1,000 first deposit
bonus double your first deposit use
promo code riffin to activate the offer
visit my bookie online today that's my B
oh okay ie and don't forget to use the
promo code riffin when creating your
account to claim your bonus my bookie
bet when get paid now back to the
podcast yeah that's well that's I mean I
you know so funny laughs at the Comedy
Store I got that from I knew who he was
was Tony Robbins oh wow he saw me at The
Comedy Store one night perform it and
gave me a bunch of money to come and do
his birthday party his 40th birthday
party so that it's crazy when people
I've done some crazy things like that I
did this show just do it it was just it
was just like he was Persian yeah and he
he owned like beauty supply of course
and he was like 500 ah whatever it was
right but it was like yeah just come
make fun of my friends and I was like
all right I get to his house this is
just dumb now you mad that he only got
500
cuz in his garage I'll never forget this
his garage was all mirrors oh wow
because he wanted to see self-driving in
his Ferrari from every angle he wanted
to Ferrari to pull into the garage and
he wanted to get out and see him he
wanted to be that like slow-motion Miami
Vice you know hit the hit the jacket a
little fan there to make it work give
all this dude is crazy so you know you
do those kind of like weird shows but
it's like I'm just saying like you know
you know you don't know who people are
what you know what I will do exactly and
I feel like people who are the most
secure and who they are what they do
they don't have to lead with you think
I'm enough yeah it's like this is what I
do and you know I mean so I mean you
know for me too as I've never been big
on
I've known see let me start like this
I've never been big on like the fame of
it
mm-hmm so like like being all
workaholics mm-hmm
was it was huge whereas for people that
loved that show yes they see me and
they're like oh right they love the show
is right right right but I never got
paid I never delved too much into it
because I didn't want to miss it when it
was gone yeah cuz you know it's gonna be
over eventually I had and I see enough
of my comedian friends who from
different levels here who who has heart
who were doing it and then they're not
doing it anymore and they I could see in
her face did they miss it yeah they
can't adjust to being back because it
was all whoo there was everything yeah
so for me now it's like I just you know
you know and I never know cuz you know
you never know cuz especially in LA I
remember this girl came up to me and she
was like oh my god you know I know you
mm-hmm you know yeah I didn't want to be
like well you know I have one of those
faces that's that's my answer unless you
said we go to the same restaurant in ICU
even they're eating all the time I know
you I was like thank you each x2 it's
like okay I didn't want to be like oh
here we go
I'm a comedian nah ain't that
I recommend cuz it didn't Wow I have one
one buddy I go out with it like he he'll
be the one to be like that table over
there knows who you are yeah yeah I
think these people are gonna come over
and say hi right me for me I'm just like
okay we just live in ya if they do
that's fine but if not that's fine too
yeah I get that from this is so funny
you say that I've been doing stand-up 20
years I've been doing Instagram for a
year I get stopped every day see that's
what it is every single day somebody
stops me about Instagram every day
I'm not when I'm telling you I'm gonna
I'm done [ __ ] around like it's to the
point where when I'm out with my
daughters it's a game where they go okay
I bet today three people recognize dad
from Instagram like it's becomes I can't
believe it well this podcast world is
the same kind of thing is it see if
something seems like for me it's like
you know I was on TV for 13 straight
years three different shows and stuff
like that and podcast it's a podcast
that like gets people to it's a new
watch you give people like that's right
I can that's fantastic or like I saw in
the consistency it's the consistency and
because a lot of people is so many other
ways to reach people this phone this
phone has doubled my ticket sales in
comedy clubs yeah I can't believe it
I cannot I've been walking out on stage
to people going right now who is this my
whole career yeah
just eight months ago I walked out and
they were tears as promised
yeah I never felt nothing like that in
my life I've been doing this 20 years
I've never felt so you know and that's
how you know you gotta love it yeah
because you do something for this long
for what you consider to be a minimal
amount of attention if you will for
whatever you know but that phone that
meant did you start out in Cleveland no
I started out in Maryland after I got it
the Navy oh how long were you in a four
years before years yeah I didn't go to
the military to serve my country we're
going to the military to nice go to jail
yes I went to the military because I was
drinking and what do
not Nelson I just go to the military
everybody else in there drinking and
getting paid so I did that I I was a
nurse I yes I big I started off as a
medic and the way I chose my fields when
I went down to the recruiters office was
I was like what jobs do you have this in
the air conditioner I don't want to be
outside I don't want to be in no boats I
need to have a something military office
that's like that was my answer they're
like what do you want to do I said what
y'all got this in the air conditioner
swear to god that was my answer she was
like you can work in the hospital I said
oh that's cool now did you have to go to
like did you have medical training up to
that point no oh wow I went to a course
gold where they wear day you know it was
like a three or four-month school where
they show you how to do all the basic
stuff and I went did that and then after
I did that I went and worked at a
hospital and then I started getting more
and more experienced and then I went to
school at night and got my other
credentials
yeah so then I when I first came out
here like right around the corner here
right from around the corner from Sony
Studios I managed a family practice
clinic there for five years
Oh see why you think you know somebody
sitting here like you actually a
reputable you left a regular good job to
be telling jokes yeah I was I worked as
a nurse for ten years
before I before I actually could make a
living doing stand-up and writing
television so then when you okay so then
you went to the Navy you met when'd you
meet uh Gary Owen I've met Gary Owens at
the end of I was out of the military he
was about to get out he was I was in San
Diego I did a show somewhere and he came
to the show and afterwards he was like I
want to be a comedian I'm about to get
out to military I want to be a comedian
can you show me give me some tips I said
come by the apartment Oh chucka showing
him to trade show them write a resume
here's get a headshot do all this stuff
I said he's like I'm going to LA next
week I got a friend who knows somebody
I'm about to go up there I was moving up
to LA from San Diego
like nine months from that moment I was
like I'd be up there in about nine
months he'd go in now he was kidding out
and going I typed up my girl below that
I was with at the time typed up the
resume put all this [ __ ] together suckle
all these contacts true when I got to LA
I think it was on every billboard in
down I said it was the comedy store fat
Tuesdays he was he was off and running
but he was always funny yeah he's funny
Geir was always funny produces I
produced his reality
I mean his reality show oh I didn't know
that huh yeah yeah you think you know
somebody
yeah I get why I bother with him you
know yeah cuz why Wes why we're friends
you know yeah you have that you know
this sort of just sort of like
camaraderie that Brotherhood that we
have yeah so then when you finally some
went like when did it start you click
him for you as I just started clicking
for me like I feel like very early
stand-up wash things that click like i
showcase for the Comedy Store for Mitzi
shore one time and I got in and I got
picked up as a pay regular in the main
room so like I immediately started
working at The Comedy Store Pauly Shore
got me a an audition for his mom and I
literally I showcased one time and she
called me over and was like imma putting
you in my main room she says I haven't
put anybody from showcase night straight
to the main room since Eddie Griffin 10
years before you I didn't know that so
when I first started at The Comedy Store
everybody used to come into the room to
watch me and I didn't know why I thought
they were just supportive oh my god is
so supportive group of people right but
I didn't know that there is this Mitsy
picked up straight to the main room I
didn't know that you could showcase time
and time and time again I have two shows
twice and never get or get into just a
belly room or an hour unpaid regular or
just two or like you had to move up to
the main room I had no clue of that I
just moved here from Maryland I just
thought I wanted to be a comedian yeah
yeah yeah you know I'm saying so when I
got picked up and put in the mayor I
thought that was a regular thing to do I
didn't
I didn't know you know me and then I
same thing happened at the Reetha Jones
introduced me to Jamie Masada and I
showcase tonight Nick Cannon came in
with his mother she was bringing him he
was a 17 year old kid and I Nick went up
before me we had a good set then I went
up after him and I played off of some of
the stuff he did killed and Jamie Masada
pick me up so it's like I just so very
early on as a comedian I got picked up
at all the comedy clubs very quickly and
I just started working you know I just
didn't know the business I didn't know
anybody I knew no origin or didn't I
remember those days for myself is like
it's not even about not knowing their
business you didn't realize that you
needed to know the business you just
want you thought to just being a
comedian and being on stage somebody was
gonna come tap you when you walked up
with a cutting this way they always say
it's not a deli yes no were you like you
gotyou they're not going like Dave
Arnold right none of that doesn't work
like they does not work like
[ __ ] that come to LA then you
think they think they really think it
works like that hey I'm gonna keep my
time right and it doesn't you have to
know what to do you have to know when to
do it what you don't need to do anymore
all of that stuff so it's like you know
I got a show called black man revealed
on TV one that I hosted the first year I
got that I landed that show and that's
when I quit my day job and you know I
did it for one season they fire me I'm
at the end of the season they said I
wasn't black enough and Wow how did that
for you uh I was infuriated yeah because
they didn't grow up in Cleveland when
one of you back
what told you he couldn't play with you
no more because you was a [ __ ] like
what like what do you what do you think
that meant to them like what that I
wasn't what the people who were making
decisions in that office at the time
whatever their experience or whatever
they thought that black people thought
black people look like I've been through
that my whole career here though as a
comedian I've gotten you don't look like
a comedian I've gotten you know
I'll say it I've gotten you don't look
like a comedian I've gotten you don't
look at me I know I've seen pictures of
me from 10 you know I've I can very well
look Mexican and Hispanic important
Rican I got yes you get it we from so
you get all of that you know I mean like
I've gotten all of that and it's too bad
because the thing about that when you
get that from black people when they
tell you that you're not black enough or
you don't look like with black or
whatever they have deemed to be in an
eighties light-skinned that was in now
that's not like when you do that kind of
stuff you you know it both blame black
have to deal with like skin a
dark-skinned black your [ __ ] like
when you live skin yeah you have to be
like you know you gotta be cute like El
DeBarge right for them to be like
accepting right but if you just regular
things just like whoa I don't even know
I don't know put you you know it's like
it is so when you deal with all of that
on top like you have to deal with not
being white yeah you know I mean only I
tell you the time I had to deal with
that as a comedian I wanted to become a
regular at The Improv and so I went over
there to go I'd every club I walked in
that did this you know I want to be a
regular how do I do that like literally
I was that dude like cuz if you tell me
you got to go outside and run around the
block ten times okay you kick back like
okay what was that that's who I was when
I got to this town yeah I just wanted to
be on stage and be funny and I remember
they said our Erin who ran the club at
that she was in the club at the time she
now is incorporate every ones every call
gotcha right she said well you need to
come and showcase oh no no no this what
she did to me
first time you need to do funny faces of
fresh faces I said fine Josh wolf was
Dov was the person who was running funny
fresh faces of it yeah yeah I at the
time you had tapes VHS tapes of your set
this is when I came home from school
yeah
I got us I got a tape I gave I said came
to Johnson said Josh Aaron said I should
come and do your show fresh faces funny
you know he looked at my set I had a set
from something I had done he literally
said to me you're too polished that's
what the [ __ ] he said to me yeah nobody
knew me yeah I've been in town for 12
minutes he said I was too polished I
went back to Aaron Josh said I was too
polished she said let me see one of
these polishes tapes that josh is
talking about I gave her the tape of
course three weeks later
mm-hmm yes that is true so I'm gonna
give you a showcase here mm-hmm
I want to see you you know come to
Monday night at though what Monday night
was you know bubb's mo better Monday's
was too you know still that was yes it
was that mean it was the Amos you know
and I say that's like combat comedy
right and I said wait Monday night was
the black night stili it's just you know
just heart just [ __ ] fide yeah and I
immediately became offended and I said
why do I have to showcase on Monday
because I'm black I said does the Josh
wolf have to showcase on Monday when he
came here and you look on her face was
like oh [ __ ] what the [ __ ] about done
yeah me yeah and they gave me a regular
spot right on whatever you know Tuesday
whatever night you know and I never
heard from them again I do all the
improv right but like the improv in
Hollywood every smile but way back in
those days when I was young and just
trying to come up I just skinny just
bitter and arrogant right I used to be a
craze to go to like see the improv this
and I'd be like is this Schindler's List
yes I was like but it was like that's
just stupid you know cuz they go get you
no way even though it's true it's not
gonna help your case
yeah so I mean I remember just all oh
man I remember my I have so many bad
experiences like I remember I got knee
surgery right I was 26 right you know
and I uh 25 crunches right right and the
dude just dude my he's killing me I need
you to host at The Improv you know cover
for me at home I said no right of course
you know so what we love it yeah go on
stage nothing from the crowd
Wow like it was just and I had to bring
up the first comic I had to bring up was
a earthquake oh wait
what was this app this is just a regular
there was a trending regular night okay
guys no no the knife Scout comic I
brought it was Dana Gould
oh god okay just one of the rise is not
a gun these dudes just for murder I was
like [ __ ] what am i doing
I'll never forget that I'm just thinking
that's the first time I started to think
like huh no this is for me really yeah I
don't know if I could do this I don't
think I'm like I've never had that
thought yeah vomit yeah yeah just I was
like I never liked my experience cuz I
didn't know what I was doing I don't
know what even approach comedy right
that's why I stopped for so long I
didn't really I didn't really start
right I always consider my start as when
I was thirty that's when I really
started you know I started doing when I
was 30 I started at 28 yeah so but this
is but I tried when I was 22 I try when
I was 18 yeah so all in one time and I
live in LA I was born and raised in LA
so oh I didn't know that yeah so trying
to be in LA trying to do this was just
like oh why there man
oh I had this like like like mixed nuts
which is nasty comedy yeah yeah it makes
nuts like I remember going there doing
this show and I'll never forget this
I've told this story on another podcast
but this is my [ __ ] now but I so Jay
Anthony Brown's - host yes I remember
that he was working with this girl off
account her name I know who you talking
about I'm talking about
so she she didn't tell him to line up
right so he's awesome but he's on stage
killing of course like like killing
like the crowd is life right in ways
right and then you look over at the
commies next right
literally I'm in the front everybody
went like this and let you stand in
there right right right
the worst kind of bring up yes you know
it'd be like I wouldn't want him to set
me up on a first date because he'd be
like his mama about to ask you to split
the check I'm nervous cuz I was like
afraid of black crowds at the time yes
I've been like you know and so so like a
minute II and I'm getting the light okay
Wow you know he's I'm he's waving it
like I go I say on stage yeah I got to
light already damn okay I finish up he
goes on stage
and he does listen to me Dave David a
ornament J Anthony Brown does 20 on how
terrible I was okay I was sitting in the
back on a stool taking it taking it I'm
not gonna leave not right right right
here go here you go hey go honey ain't
gonna make me run you ain't running me
out of this play right I even remember
one the jokes he was like yeah you had
like [ __ ]
we said no girlfriends on fire to get
him off stage people pouring gasoline on
people oh you know get off you know so I
was like then it's that kind of energy
where none of the other comas wanted to
even look at me right want to come near
me and I'm just sitting here like this I
tell you I didn't do comedy for eight
months after that
really yeah just shook me at the time
where I was like this isn't fun I don't
like this nobody else's job you know go
to work
and [ __ ] up the filing system and the
boss hand in front of the cafeteria and
go you know you know why [ __ ] VIN J is
in K write this [ __ ] right here
he don't know how to fight like no
nobody destroy you like that minute saw
it just really hurt my confidence Wow
and it was until when I got back into
again I'm 30 31
yeah I realize I remember I was doing
this show out in Phoenix at Marley's
mm-hmm Dan Majerle had a bar okay and so
somebody booked me right you know it is
my first time I feel special too because
it was the first time when I got on at
the airport
yes somebody had your name on the side
and all you made it that's when I
thought I made it I was like okay cue to
a hotel room took me to the hotel yeah
that's a club and it's a black night oh
not just a black it was a [ __ ] night is
strange Megan it was crazy I was like oh
[ __ ] how did they get me in how do you
know what this is terrible to say but I
was like the way they treat me my cousin
ray ray gonna pick you up but he got to
get his kids first let's put eight kids
in the car right so I heard a host goes
up he's not doing well
oh wow I'll never forget this it was a
weird night right he got he ain't doing
well right and then I go up and I'm
struggling I mean I'm like come to win
everything I can all right I'm sweating
I'm if I'm dancing I'm throwing I'm like
I'm sitting I'm doing everything I can
when I got offstage did this with the DJ
play okay oh my god wait how much time
did you do like 10 15 whenever it was
and then the host goes on and now he
finds he's all like well I know what
they coming back here and you kept
saying it and I'm sitting in the back
I'm sitting back I'm laughing so then
the next guy goes up this other dude was
his name but he ain't doing good right
nobody's doing well but he to the point
wait his room he goes like this until he
goes it
[ __ ] y'all I already got paid you know
that's how bad the night was and then D
militant was headline oh wow he tried
his best to do okay but this is the part
that I knew I was gonna be okay the
emcee comes off stage and he walks over
it he sees me at the bar uh-huh he's
like oh [ __ ] are you still here oh you
still gonna show you I want my dish I
was like you killing me man it's
hilarious right this is this is funny
what you do and it's the moment I knew
oh I'm gonna be okay right right moment
that it didn't matter to me anymore
right
I bombed there but I was like I don't
give a [ __ ] I can make it I can make it
that's that's what I tell people in and
and I've talked to you about coming to
talk to my class oh because I you know I
teach a stand-up class which is it's the
largest class in the country I mean it's
like one of them but it's really like we
have like I think now we up to like
three hundred and some-odd people on my
waiting list which I didn't know until
my assistant told me yeah maybe I need
to come be a guest professor you should
definitely come and you can have to
class oh well I'd this one that I just
started yesterday I actually I only
normally do ten students uh-huh because
I like to like try to really really help
do I know y'all get it I got twenty this
particular is the first time I've ever
done this just like a black publish oh
is that we're doing two showcases
back-to-back you don't really like I
can't put them all on one show but this
is what I told them - what you said
comedians this is there's a difference
between a comedian and somebody who's
funny a comedian will bomb but the
bombing will make them have to go to a
comedy club again to try to figure out
why they bomb it won't make you run away
it'll make you more intrigued I told him
I was young I ran away
you ran see like I I did - when I was 18
I did comedy one time in Cleveland open
mic night it might have been four people
in the room maybe 12 I went up I did
something got nothing
yeah and then I walked off and I walked
off and was like you know I never I
didn't go back because I didn't know
that I should go back right you know I
mean I did um I was in Atlanta I just
got out of the military and I was
starting my career as a comedian and my
mom would actually went to the club with
me this night and earthquake was the
host it was his Club uptown comedy
corner right this is this is like the
late 90s early 2000 probably and I go up
to do I do that spot before he
you know that pre-show [ __ ] taking it
all about the face like just I'm like
yeah I'm getting nothing right this
thinkin comes out and does 20 minutes on
how horrible I was it's not that I was
there my mama was so what why would you
be like you know you don't believe it
all that and I would never forget like
riding home with her and my stepfather
was with us both of them was you know
and cyclists I mean it just but this is
what I can honestly say it never made me
go I can't do this it's not for me the
only thing it made me go is I say to
myself is I'm going to figure this out
yeah I didn't see I didn't get to that
point until 2003 when I started going to
open mics by myself and realizing that
this was about networking that it was
yes
it was about making your peers laugh yes
like who knows you cultivating
relationships and it wasn't till then
that I started it really opened up for
me and then I and then I was off and
running right because what was
frustrating to me was like I was around
when Jim Gaffigan was going to open mics
Wow Kennedy was sleeping on people's
couches okay so I saw all these people
and like and then like a group of people
that I sort of saw coming up was like
you know Sebastian and Brent yes so when
I saw those guys so then cut to when I'm
coming back into it they're already
doing [ __ ] in this language so I've
always been like oh I gotta catch up and
I can't quit because you know because
everybody else cuz everybody um like
four or five years ago I was at another
club perform and quake was hosted mm-hm
and he brought and he brought me up I
killed came onstage he went back up he
did ten minutes oh how brilliant I was
say there you go and I asked him when it
was over IRA told him about this time in
Atlanta fifteen years earlier right he
had known that you know comics he had a
family exactly and I realized that
something that didn't even move the
needle in his world
yeah change the course of mine me too I
know exactly what you're saying
you know I'm saying so like as people as
a comedian you I always tell people
they've sent my class I go you gotta you
have to you you gonna find out whether
you a comedian are you just somebody to
spike a class to when I first started
you know did you I'd never need I never
even knew was a class yeah I took a
class just because I took this and my
mom signed me up for it cuz I told her
what comic and she was like well here
you go
boom boom boom boom and I was like oh
hey oh my mom is right right oh that's
toe if I wanted to be a rock climber she
would assign me I bought ropes and hooks
oh that's tough
so that's why you know I always
attributed to hers like you know that
kind of pushing their motivation you
know yeah but then it's like it wasn't
like I said it was until later in my
career that like you know even it like
like I still like I've had so many
experiences at black comedy rooms yeah
that like made me be like I don't know I
wanna go black one right you know right
you know what's funny Wow let me tell
you something that when I first got here
no no but I'm saying what's great about
this that you're here I wanted to know
this yeah the time that I did a black
room and was like now I'm never gonna
worry about this again huh it was when
all right so it's me you and Chris
Spencer and we outed that [ __ ]
casino gig at the Laugh Factory does
okay
Oh Bernadine Oh another thing she was
like it's because you all had to sit
outside like in the room so I'm doing my
bit I remembered us and you two are
laughing okay so yes cut you now drew so
you guys are laughing this is in my
estimation this is the first time you
actually are acknowledging me as a
comedian okay really yes it's only
because I get it though because we don't
watch people no because we too worried
about
if we're friends we're just like yes the
club's booking him so I think he's okay
yes well people have to really watch you
to be like okay I think this guy's fun
yes exactly
now Giroux he'd run yes tripping on
Tuesday to guess so yes I'm not friends
with him I'm casual he's he's the kind
of [ __ ] at the time they'd be
like oh yeah I'm gonna get you on the
show
right right so now I'm at The Comedy
Store right is to it's a Tuesday right
and he's giving me the runaround again
right Kristen Spencer steps in he goes
no write a book him right put them all
put them on yeah so then I that was the
first time I remember doing that room
and being like oh I realized something
that black audiences are just as scared
of you as you are of them it was all in
your head it was all in my head and I
just [ __ ] like you know murdered and
now I just I don't know man I don't care
because you funny
you know why because you're funny you
realized it funny but this is funny no
matter where you go there's things I
have to do sometimes like you know
sometimes I think you got a different
thing right you know I've played dead
stupid Atlanta comedy fierce uptown how
many going on those do they Atlanta
Comedy Theatre yeah nightmare yes I'll
go there once a year it's not yes yes
fool yeah who the owner yeah um Gary
Gary fool yes yes I know him Yeah right
because when you see the words Atlanta
Comedy Theatre you think it's a theater
you think it's a no you think it's like
a normal setup Langstrom comedy club
I'll say no that was just it's just a
room what seats in it yeah just to get
to green rooms yes every comic in
Atlanta did a guest says yes if you let
yeah
you got a you got to shut that down you
didn't know I went into the other green
room and I just said just let me know
when I'm going up that's hilarious
yes cuz I don't care that's the truck of
the black comedian and I don't know if
every by comedian goes through that but
like when I first when I first moved
here I had been on the road for two
years and I had just come back I got
lucky I don't know how I got a
six months into doing stand-up that
legitimately could put me on the road I
was on the road like two years straight
like never liked but you're making [ __ ]
money yeah but I was so excited to be a
comedian I was getting $700 at the end
of the week I could not believe it
like I was like you understand I
understand like I would get home with
less money then I had when I left
realize I was like okay that flight cost
six yeah and I had to eat none of that
nothing I was getting paid to tell jokes
and I remember coming here so I had been
doing comedy for two years all around
the country most of the clubs were white
so all the crowds were white unless I
was opening for Jamie Foxx or I was
opening for Steve Harvey when I would
because I would feature to whoever was
happen to be the headliner at the time
gotcha so when I came here it was until
I moved to LA that I realized oh there's
a black comedy scene and a white cop I
didn't realize that yeah so I had to
learn how I couldn't do fat Tuesday's
chocolate sundaes mo better in the
beginning they wouldn't even let me
watch I was a pay regular at The Comedy
Store they wouldn't let me in the main
room on Tuesday night I was like yeah
but this thing I'm gonna do with the
clown is independent people in their
stores [ __ ] blowing up setting
themselves on fire I would be in the
original room performing in here the
fire yeah you coming through the wall
and I was like I want to be over there
yeah yeah you really wanted to be over
there and then I got my chance and I
[ __ ] died because I didn't have that
confidence right right right right I
didn't have none of that so what I did
is I found every black comedy room that
I could find I'll use down he was down
at Hollywood Park Casino right I did
when I tell you I I was a regular at
economy store The Laugh Factory the ice
house that's what I that was my three
main all the time but I would always go
and do these two or three I would do
mixed nuts I would
Hollywood Park Casino on other nights
this other place called the main and the
main rave room I did I would do those
just to go down and be in front of black
crowds and take it in the face until I
learned to get my confidence yeah
and that's how I got my confidence and
now you know you stand in front of
people in a don't matter don't matter
they don't matter sometimes even like I
remembered like I did this show like
outside uh it wasn't Utah but it was in
that sort of area yeah you know like I
remember the comic did the owner calls
me hey man can you come all right the
beginning of the sentence
can you come because we got a
ventriloquist because we got a private
party of people and he just come do a
little time before the ventriloquist
okay so when I get there if there's a
senior citizen it's a senior citizens
type of thing so it's a lot of old
people yes a lot it's crazy
yes yeah I'm at the tail end of them
doing bingo right do got the mic right
and he's yelling you know be okay they
got the mic hot these people are like I
get it you know okay so now they don't
change the mic volume and they go came
now before our main event here's a
comedian Eric Griffin
I grabbed the mic and I'm like what's up
y'all and then it's like all these old
people like so now they hate me why are
you so loud because the mic was that's
what that's what they they hate me so
then he the other comic and the comedy
club owner are in the back room dying
laughing
they are cuz I am dying a brutal death
and they are back there just like and
the owners going so then I go in the
middle of it I say alright [ __ ] y'all
and so then now they got people got
oh oh dude he has a vase that he just
won from the thing I'm like you got your
so now we got an a your wife
yeah I'm killing these old people nobody
likes me except for two women who were
like in their 50s hilarious they were
the youngest ones in the crowd they
loved me but I just remembered to myself
understanding at that point right there
that this is part of the struggle like
this is part of the process and like
you're not always gonna be funny you're
not always gonna have a good set even
last night the last night you I didn't
have the best set of my life right
because it would then I find out all the
people that were on the lineup before me
and I was like oh yeah this crowd
they're done oh wow there was some heavy
hitters only for you so just like those
things man so you just you just take
your lumps and I feel like what I
realized is the lumps don't stop they
just come at different levels different
levels different times it says and it's
it's you know what you gotta be built
for this it's a marathon
it ain't a 50-yard dash and if you will
know if you built because you learn to
pace yourself yeah you learn to pace
yourself and you know and enjoy the ride
that's what I'm doing and you're doing
it and doing it well and having ball I
think this is a good stopping point man
i'ma have you on again I really
appreciate the conversation because I
don't even get into some of the walking
so I wanted to get into the state of
black comedy and I know I thought we
were let's do it again that not do I do
I want because I like having repeat
guests I think like you know people
enjoy the conversation so we got to keep
it going but I might have dead what you
got coming up
I just put my stand-up special in the
can so we're doing a deal right now with
Netflix so that's gone that's all great
good for you so I'm very excited about
how that works on me too but if you can
get on there knocking give me me - I'm
really it's very funny it's called fat
ballerina it's very funny I'm I'm out
developing I'm getting ready go back out
develop some new stuff for my you know
my manager and finishing a fuller house
where I'm you know
fuller house this is the last hurrah we
just filmed
this the other day we just filmed one of
the big moments in this 18 episode run
so cuz how many seasons this would be
five seasons and that's rare on Netflix
yeah this is it [ __ ] this is the most
successful show on Netflix you know
people don't recognize that which is
crap wait I didn't know it exists
because they don't go past three seasons
yeah they're doing five and it's the
most successful reboot ever you know I
mean like other shows are being
repressive show - that's what it's ansel
initiative no I don't like honestly what
I feel like is that all the stories have
been told it's a perfect time to stop
yeah and it's going out and given in
it's fulfilling these characters that
have been brought back after 30 years so
it's kind of dope to be a part of
something as so iconic that to be honest
with I wasn't really locked into in the
nineties when I was that wasn't my show
full house but to watch these actors
bring this to life is kind of dope to
watch them come back so you know I'm
doing at and I'm developing a couple of
other show ideas and just tour man I'm
about to go back out on tour in the
beginning of the year soon as we wrap so
I'm you know putting dates on the
calendar and film I have all the Dave's
David's information right below that'll
be down all the links and all that kind
of stuff you could you could find him
and we may become a new fan and he's got
he's gonna you could hear him on a radio
soon and all you know and all that kind
of stuff and you look out for a special
fat ballerina it'll be on something it
will be it will be you know so I'm very
excited about it's great and thank you
for coming on thanks for having me man
and you know we'll look for him to come
back on again and I want you guys thanks
thank you for listening make sure you
subscribe hit that subscribe button hit
that like button and keep supporting
riffing with Griffin I appreciate it and
I'll keep bringing the guests and you
just keep joining this free content I
thank you for the lovers and even the
haters thanks again just been riffing
with Griffin I'll see you next week